ласкаво просимо назад до курсу «Розуміння квантової інформації та обчислень». Мене звуть John Watrous, я технічний директор з освіти в IBM
Quantum. Це 12-й урок серії і останній урок третього блоку, присвяченого загальній
формулюванню квантової інформації. Цей урок зосереджений навколо фундаментального поняття квантової інформації, а саме
очищення квантового стану. Очищення квантового стану, представленого деякою матрицею густини, — це
чистий стан більшої складеної системи, який залишає нам початковий стан, коли решту складеної системи
відкинуто або виведено. Кожна матриця густини має очищення, і ми можемо багато дізнатися
про квантові стани та про квантову інформацію загалом, вивчаючи очищення. На інтуїтивному рівні
вектори квантових станів, що представляють чисті стани, є простішими математичними об'єктами, ніж матриці густини. Думаючи про
очищення станів, ми можемо розглядати довільні квантові стани систем як частини чогось більшого, але
простішого. Ми також поговоримо про вірність між двома квантовими станами — це значення, яке кількісно визначає їхню
подібність або перекриття. Воно часто використовується як спосіб вимірювання того, наскільки хорошим є певний стан у порівнянні з
деяким ідеальним станом. Зокрема, ми обговоримо визначення вірності разом із деякими її основними властивостями, і ми побачимо,
як вірність пов'язана з очищеннями. Ось огляд уроку: ми почнемо з очищень, включаючи
визначення та простий доказ їхнього існування, який розповідає нам, як знайти одне, якщо воно нам потрібне. Потім ми обговоримо те, що відоме
як розклад Шмідта вектора квантового стану двох систем, і ми побачимо, як розклади Шмідта пов'язані з
очищеннями. Далі ми обговоримо критично важливе відношення між будь-якими двома очищеннями одного й того самого стану, яке відоме як унітарна
еквівалентність очищень. І нарешті, ми розглянемо кілька прикладів. Потім ми перейдемо до вірності,
включаючи її визначення та деякі основні властивості. Ми поговоримо про лему про м'яке вимірювання, яка є дуже
зручним фактом, що пов'язує вірність із вимірюваннями. І нарешті, щоб завершити урок, ми звернемося до теореми Уламана, яка
встановлює фундаментальний зв'язок між вірністю та очищеннями. Почнімо з
визначення очищення. Очищення стану, який, припустимо, представлений деякою матрицею
густини, — це чистий стан більшої складеної системи, який залишає початковий стан, з якого ми почали, коли решту
складеної системи виведено. Ми можемо висловити це точніше в математичних термінах таким чином:
якщо у нас є система X, що перебуває в деякому стані ρ, тобто ρ є матрицею густини, що представляє стан X,
а |ψ⟩ є вектором квантового стану пари систем XY таким, що виведення Y з чистого стану |ψ⟩⟨ψ|
залишає нам ρ, то ми кажемо, що |ψ⟩ є очищенням ρ. Звісно, назви не мають значення — ми
можемо назвати наші системи та стани як завгодно, і порядок систем також не має значення. Наприклад,
якби система Y була ліворуч, а не праворуч, але все інше залишалося б таким самим, ми б все одно називали |ψ⟩ очищенням ρ. Але ми
переважно дотримуватимемося цього порядку до кінця уроку просто заради простоти. Перше, що варто сказати
про визначення, — це те, що очищення завжди існують для кожної матриці густини ρ. Якщо бути точнішим, кожна
матриця густини ρ має очищення, як описано у визначенні, за умови, що система Y є принаймні такою ж великою, як X, тобто
Y має принаймні стільки ж класичних станів, скільки й X. Поняття очищення та
той факт, що очищення завжди існують, виявляється критично важливим і є частиною того, що робить квантову інформацію красивою. Я сподіваюся
переконати тебе в цьому факті до кінця уроку. Тепер доведімо, що кожна матриця густини має очищення, і в
процесі ми побачимо, як отримати очищення, коли воно нам потрібне. Так само, як у визначенні,
припустимо, що X є системою, а ρ — матрицею густини, що представляє стан
X. Тепер розглянемо будь-який вираз ρ як опуклу комбінацію чистих станів, як ми написали на екрані. Словами,
для деякого вибору додатного цілого числа n ми маємо вектор ймовірностей p₀ до p_, а також вектори
квантових станів |φ₀⟩ до |φ_⟩, і усереднюючи відповідні чисті стани, зважені за ймовірностями, ми
отримуємо ρ. Наприклад, ми могли б використати спектральну теорему, щоб отримати такий вираз для ρ. Якщо ми це зробимо,
ми можемо взяти n рівним кількості класичних станів X. Насправді ми можемо взяти n рівним рангу ρ, який
дорівнює кількості ненульових власних значень ρ, де кожне власне значення враховується стільки разів, скільки його кратність, —
і це ніколи не більше, ніж кількість класичних станів X, але може бути менше. З іншого боку, це
не обов'язково має бути спектральним розкладом ρ, і нам не потрібно, щоб ці вектори квантових станів були ортогональними. Наприклад, будь-який такий вираз ρ
цілком підходить. І ось очищення ρ — сума береться за тими самими значеннями, що й
у нашому виразі ρ, і всередині суми ми беремо квадратні корені ймовірностей, помножені на |φₐ⟩, тензорно
помножені на |a⟩. До речі, тут ми припускаємо, що 0 до n-1 є класичними станами другої системи Y, тому
цілком має сенс, що |ψ⟩ є вектором квантового стану пари XY, як у визначенні. Насправді
тут не важливо, що ми використовуємо стандартні базисні стани Y у цьому виразі. Ти міг би підставити будь-яку ортонормовану сукупність
станів замість |0⟩ до |n-1⟩, якщо захочеш. І тепер ми можемо перевірити, що це справді
є очищенням, обчисливши частковий слід по Y. Ось вираз стану, який ми отримуємо, виконуючи частковий слід.
Слід від |a⟩⟨b| дорівнює або одиниці, або нулю залежно від того, чи рівне a рівне b. Тому вираз
спрощується до нашого початкового виразу ρ, і все так просто. Тому отримати очищення дуже легко —
потрібно лише мати достатньо класичних станів Y або, альтернативно, достатньо велику ортонормовану множину для використання
замість стандартних базисних станів |0⟩ до |n-1⟩. До речі, якщо кількість
класичних станів Y менша за ранг ρ, то очищення не існуватиме — залишаю це тобі
на роздуми, якщо захочеш. Ось приклад: розглянемо
матрицю густини, яку ми бачили кілька разів на уроці про матриці густини. Ось вираз цієї
матриці густини як опуклої комбінації чистих станів. Це не спектральний розклад, але нам
все одно. І майже без жодних зусиль ми можемо записати очищення стану, слідуючи
рецепту. Це не єдине очищення цієї матриці густини — очищення не є унікальними, але це нормально.
WEBVTT
Визначення нічого не говорить про унікальність, і насправді між різними очищеннями одного й того самого стану існує дуже цікаве відношення, але
ми обговоримо це трохи пізніше на уроці. Далі ми розглянемо розклади Шмідта — це вирази
двочасткових векторів квантових станів у певній формі, яку я опишу за мить. Вони названі на честь Ерхарда
Шмідта — того самого Шмідта, відомого процедурою ортогоналізації Грама–Шмідта. Але у випадку розкладів Шмідта їх, мабуть, не варто
називати на честь Шмідта: математично це еквівалентно тому, що називається розкладом за сингулярними значеннями матриць, що
насправді було перевідкрито кілька разів, але таке трапляється. Утім, ось що ми маємо на увазі
під розкладом Шмідта: для довільного вибору вектора квантового стану |ψ⟩ для пари
систем XY завжди можна записати |ψ⟩ в спеціальній формі. Ця форма така, як
показано на екрані, де R є деяким додатнім цілим числом, p₀ до p_ є додатніми дійсними числами, що
разом утворюють вектор ймовірностей, |x₀⟩ до |x_⟩ є одиничними векторами, що відповідають системі X, а |y₀⟩
до |y_⟩ є одиничними векторами, що відповідають системі Y. Це може не виглядати особливим,
поки я не скажу тобі, що обидві множини — |x₀⟩ до |x_⟩ та |y₀⟩ до |y_⟩ — мають бути
ортонормованими. То чому це особливо? Якби ми вибрали будь-який базис для одного з двох базисів, скажімо
X-вектори, що відповідають системі X, то ми завжди могли б виразити |ψ⟩ у цій формі, і це змусило б нас
вибирати Y-вектори певним чином. Насправді ми робимо це досить рутинно, як зі стандартним базисом, коли готуємося
аналізувати стандартне базисне вимірювання. Але загалом, навіть якщо ми вибираємо ортонормований базис для X-векторів,
Y-вектори, які ми отримаємо, не обов'язково будуть ортонормованими. Аналогічно, якщо вибрати
ортонормований базис для Y-векторів і спробувати виразити |ψ⟩ у цій формі, можна, але X-вектори
не обов'язково будуть ортонормованими. І нарешті, якщо вибрати ортонормовані вектори для обох систем і
спробувати виразити |ψ⟩ у такій формі, це не обов'язково спрацює, бо може виявитися, що потрібні якісь перехресні члени. Але є лише один
індекс у цій сумі — a, — тому форма є особливою, але її завжди можна
записати для даного одиничного вектора |ψ⟩. Ось як це можна зробити: спочатку обчисли спектральний розклад
редукованого стану будь-якої з двох систем — не має значення якої. Але для зручності описання розглянемо редукований стан
X: виводимо Y, тобто p₀ до p_ є власними
значеннями цього редукованого стану ρ, а |x₀⟩ до |x_⟩ є одиничними власними векторами, що відповідають цим власним значенням. До
речі, тут мається на увазі, що ми ігноруємо члени, для яких власні значення дорівнюють нулю, бо ці члени нічого не додають до
суми. Тобто p₀ до p_ — усі додатні дійсні числа, а R — кількість ненульових
власних значень з урахуванням кратностей, що дорівнює рангу ρ. Отже, ми маємо p₀ до p_,
а також |x₀⟩ до |x_⟩, і все, що залишилося, — це знайти вектори |y₀⟩ до |y_⟩.
Є лише один варіант, який може спрацювати: ці вектори на цьому етапі однозначно визначені, і їх можна
легко знайти за простою формулою, показаною на екрані. І що дивовижно тут, так це те, що
якщо ми визначимо ці вектори таким чином, вони гарантовано будуть ортонормованими, що дає нам розклад Шмідта. Я не буду доводити це у цьому
відео, але це не надто складно, і ти можеш звернутися до письмових матеріалів до уроку, якщо тебе це цікавить. Дивись
опис відео для посилання, як завжди. Як приклад розглянемо цей
вектор квантового стану, який ми отримали як очищення прикладу матриці густини, до якого ми весь час повертаємося.
Це не розклад Шмідта, тому що стани |0⟩ і |+⟩ не є ортонормованими, але ми можемо знайти його
за описаною мною процедурою. Перший крок — обчислити спектральний розклад редукованого
стану X, тобто того самого прикладу матриці густини, і ось його спектральний розклад, який ми бачили ще
на уроці 9. Отже, ми вибираємо p₀, P₁, |x₀⟩ та |x₁⟩ так, як
показано на екрані: p₀ та P₁ — власні значення ρ, а |x₀⟩ та |x₁⟩ —
відповідні одиничні власні вектори. Залишається обчислити |y₀⟩ та |y₁⟩. Якщо ми це зробимо, отримаємо |+⟩
для |y₀⟩ та -1·|−⟩ для |y₁⟩. Це не одразу очевидно, потрібно
справді виконати розрахунок, щоб це побачити, але саме так ми й отримуємо. І, як і очікувалося, ці два вектори є ортонормованими,
що буде так завжди, якщо ти виконав обчислення правильно. І це дає нам розклад
Шмідта. Розклади Шмідта дуже зручні в багатьох ситуаціях, і незабаром ми побачимо, що вони кажуть нам
про очищення. Очищення не є унікальними: даний квантовий стан, представлений матрицею
густини, насправді матиме нескінченно багато очищень. Однак між будь-якими двома очищеннями одного й того самого стану існує тісне
відношення, яке завжди виконується, і воно іноді називається унітарною
еквівалентністю очищень. Ось як це працює: нехай ρ — матриця густини,
що представляє квантовий стан системи X, і нехай у нас є два будь-яких очищення цього стану, що є
чистими станами однієї й тієї самої складеної системи. Для конкретності припустимо, що |ψ⟩ та |φ⟩
є векторами квантових станів пари систем XY, обидва з яких дають нам ρ, коли систему Y виводять.
Те, що стверджує унітарна еквівалентність очищень, — це те, що має існувати унітарна операція U, яка діє лише на
систему Y і перетворює |ψ⟩ на |φ⟩. Іншими словами, хоча це
довільні очищення ρ і ми не робимо жодних припущень про них, крім того, що вони обидва очищують ρ і є
обидва станами однієї й тієї самої складеної системи XY, — вони мають бути еквівалентними в певному сенсі, з точністю до унітарної операції лише на Y.
Ми побачимо кілька прикладів, що ілюструють, чому це цікаво і які наслідки це має, але спочатку давай
з'ясуємо, чому це правда. Почнімо зі спектрального розкладу ρ, тобто
матриці густини, яку очищують і |ψ⟩, і |φ⟩. Так само, як коли ми обговорювали розклад Шмідта, ми
припускаємо, що ми відкинули всі члени, що відповідають нульовим власним значенням. Отже, p₀ до p_
— усі додатні дійсні числа, |x₀⟩ до |x_⟩ — ортонормовані власні вектори ρ, а R є
WEBVTT
рангом ρ. До речі, зауваж, як часто ми звертаємося до спектральної теореми на цьому етапі —
це неймовірно зручний інструмент, і без нього ми були б загублені. Утім, тепер, коли у нас є спектральний
розклад ρ, ми можемо обчислити розклади Шмідта наших двох векторів так само, як раніше, і вони будуть
майже повністю однаковими. Коефіцієнти та X-вектори однакові, оскільки вони походять із спектрального розкладу редукованого стану, який
однаковий для обох векторів. Єдина відмінність у тому, що ми можемо отримати різні вектори для другої системи. Для
першого вектора |ψ⟩ ми отримаємо один набір векторів |y₀⟩ до |y_⟩, а для другого вектора |φ⟩ ми отримаємо
можливо інший набір, який ми можемо назвати |z₀⟩ до |z_⟩. Отже, тепер у нас є розклади Шмідта
для наших двох векторів, які виглядають дуже схожими, за винятком того, що вектори для другої системи можуть бути різними. Але це
розклади Шмідта, тому обидві ці сукупності є ортонормованими, і тому ми можемо просто вибрати
унітарну матрицю U, яка відправляє |yₐ⟩ у |zₐ⟩ для кожного a. Це завжди можна зробити: унітарні
операції насправді еквівалентні лінійним відображенням, що перетворюють один ортонормований базис на інший. І якщо
ці дві множини випадково не розпадаються на весь простір, що відповідає Y, ми завжди можемо розширити обидві до ортонормованих
базисів, використовуючи, що символічно, процедуру ортогоналізації Грама–Шмідта. Ось як доводиться
унітарна еквівалентність очищень. На уроці 4 серії ми обговорювали протокол надгустого кодування,
який дозволяє відправнику передати два класичних біти отримувачу, надіславши один qubit ціною одного ebit
спільної заплутаності. Я припускаю, що ти вже знайомий з цим протоколом, і мета цього прикладу — коротко
пояснити, як він пов'язаний з унітарною еквівалентністю очищень. Пам'ятай, що
протокол працює так: Alice та Bob спільно використовують ebit, тобто стан Белла |Φ⁺⟩. Alice вирішує перетворити цей
стан Белла на будь-який із чотирьох станів Белла залежно від двох бітів, які вона хоче надіслати, а потім вона надсилає свій
qubit до Bob, і він вимірює, щоб з'ясувати, який стан Белла він має. Зауваж, що всі чотири стани Белла
дають нам однаковий редукований стан для qubit Bob — повністю змішаний стан. І насправді цього вже достатньо,
щоб зробити висновок, що надгусте кодування є можливим: усі чотири стани Белла очищують повністю змішаний стан, тому з унітарної
еквівалентності очищень ми знаємо, що Alice повинна мати можливість перетворити стан Белла |Φ⁺⟩ на будь-який
інший, застосовуючи деяку унітарну операцію до свого qubit. Звісно, не важко придумати унітарні операції, які
справді спрацьовують, і вони дуже прості. Але тим не менш цікаво, що ми можемо дійти висновку, що це
можливо, навіть не думаючи про самі унітарні операції. Більше того, ми можемо зробити висновок,
що узагальнення надгустого кодування на більші системи є можливими, за умови, що у нас є спосіб узагальнити стани Белла на більші
системи так, щоб усі вони давали повністю змішаний стан як редукований стан Bob. І справді, існують різні відомі способи це зробити.
Інша область, в якій унітарна еквівалентність очищень має наслідки, — це квантова
криптографія, і один із її найважливіших наслідків полягає в тому, що вона виключає існування безумовно захищеного квантового протоколу для
криптографічного примітиву, відомого як бітове зобов'язання. То що таке бітове зобов'язання? Бітове зобов'язання — це приклад
криптографічного примітиву, під яким ми маємо на увазі низькорівневе завдання або процедуру, що забезпечує деяку базову функціональність, яка
потім може бути використана як будівельний блок для більш цікавих речей, таких як створення схем цифрового підпису або побудова
протоколів з нульовим знанням. Наприклад, у випадку бітового зобов'язання базова функціональність полягає в тому, що один
гравець Alice може взяти на себе зобов'язання щодо бінарного значення на свій вибір перед другим гравцем Bob, але її вибір залишається прихованим
до тих пір, поки вона не вирішить його розкрити. Ми вимагаємо двох конкретних властивостей від протоколу, що реалізує бітове
зобов'язання: він повинен бути зв'язуючим, тобто Alice не може змінити свою думку після того, як взяла на себе зобов'язання щодо біта, і
він повинен бути приховуючим, тобто Bob не може визначити біт Alice, поки вона не вирішить його розкрити.
Отже, було б дуже добре мати можливість реалізувати цей примітив за допомогою квантової інформації, оскільки він є
корисним примітивом, але без жодних додаткових припущень виявляється, що реалізувати його ідеально за допомогою квантової інформації неможливо, навіть близько
до ідеально. Унітарна еквівалентність очищень розкриває цей факт: на дуже високому рівні ідея полягає в тому,
що якби існував квантовий протокол для бітового зобов'язання, то мала б існувати так звана очищена версія цього протоколу, де ми можемо уявити,
що Alice має систему A, Bob має систему B, і після того, як зобов'язання взято, але до того, як Alice розкриє його, пара AB перебуває в
одному з двох чистих станів |ψ₀⟩ або |ψ₁⟩ залежно від біта, до якого Alice
зобов'язується. Якщо протокол є ідеально приховуючим, то Bob не повинен мати змоги відрізнити два
зобов'язання, тому його редукований стан повинен бути однаковим для двох варіантів. Але це означає за
унітарною еквівалентністю очищень, що Alice може перетворити будь-який з них на інший, застосовуючи деяку унітарну
операцію лише до A. Отже, протокол повністю втрачає властивість зв'язуючості. Є деталі, які
я опустив, але суть справи в тому, що унітарна еквівалентність очищень говорить нам, що цей примітив — не те,
що ми можемо надійно реалізувати за допомогою квантової інформації без додаткових припущень певного
роду. Останній приклад наслідку унітарної еквівалентності очищень — теорема, відома як
теорема Г'юстона–Джозефа–Вудерса, або скорочено теорема HJW. Почнімо з формулювання
самої теореми, і це дещо спрощена версія, щоб уникнути деяких технічних деталей і зосередитися на основних
ідеях. Припустимо, що X і Y — системи, а |φ⟩ — будь-який вектор квантового стану, що представляє чистий стан пари
XY. Тепер припустимо, що ми думаємо про редукований стан системи X окремо і придумуємо будь-який спосіб
виразити цей редукований стан як опуклу комбінацію чистих станів, як показано на екрані.
Наприклад, кількість N у цьому виразі, тобто кількість чистих станів, що усереднюються, може
бути довільно великою, можливо, набагато більшою за розмірність простору, що відповідає X або Y, для
цього питання. І що говорить нам теорема — це те, що має існувати вимірювання системи Y з N результатами, таке що
відбувається наступне: коли систему Y виміряно, по-перше, кожен результат вимірювання
з'являється з імовірністю, що точно дорівнює відповідній імовірності в нашому виразі редукованого стану X як
WEBVTT
опуклої комбінації чистих станів. По-друге, умовно на отримання певного результату вимірювання
стан X стає відповідним чистим станом з опуклої комбінації. То чому це
цікаво? Це означає, що для будь-якого способу, яким ми вирішимо думати про редукований стан X як про опуклу
комбінацію чистих станів, існує деяке вимірювання Y, яке ефективно робить цей спосіб мислення про редукований стан X
реальністю. І що примітно — це можливо навіть тоді, коли стан |φ⟩ вибирається першим, а опуклу
комбінацію вибирають пізніше. Поки це вираз редукованого стану X, існуватиме
вимірювання Y, яке спрацьовує саме так. Отже, давай подивимося, як це можна довести.
Ми починаємо з двох різних виразів для редукованого X, якому для зручності дамо назву ρ.
Далі ми вводимо нову систему Z, класичні стани якої є можливими результатами вимірювання або,
еквівалентно, індексами в нашій опуклій комбінації. Тепер ми можемо спостерігати, що наступні два вектори квантових станів
|Γ₀⟩ та |Γ₁⟩, які є векторами стану для складеної системи XYZ,
обидва є очищеннями ρ. Щоб бути зрозумілим, коли ми думаємо про ці вектори як очищення ρ, ми
думаємо про системи Y та Z разом як про одну складену систему, яку виводять, щоб залишити
ρ. Перший вектор |Γ₀⟩ по суті те саме, що початковий чистий стан |φ⟩, за тим винятком, що ми
ініціалізуємо нову систему Z станом |0⟩. Зрозуміло, що якщо ми виведемо Y та Z, у нас залишиться ρ. Отже, |Γ₀⟩
є очищенням ρ. Другий вектор |Γ₁⟩ — це по суті вектор, який ми отримуємо, очищуючи
ρ на основі опуклої комбінації, як я описував раніше на уроці. Цього разу система Y
ініціалізована, і я припускаю для простоти, що |0⟩ є класичним станом Y, але ти міг би підставити будь-який
стандартний базисний стан або насправді будь-який чистий стан Y у цей вираз, і це не мало б жодного значення. У будь-якому разі виведення Y та
Z знову залишає нас з ρ. Отже, підсумок у тому, що обидва є очищеннями ρ, і тому за
унітарною еквівалентністю очищень існує унітарна операція U на парі YZ, що перетворює |Γ₀⟩ на
|Γ₁⟩. І це все, що нам потрібно, щоб придумати опис вимірювання, яке робить те, що говорить теорема.
Простий спосіб описати це — за допомогою схемної діаграми circuit, як показано тут на екрані. Словами, ми починаємо зі
стану |φ⟩, вводимо Z, ініціалізований станом |0⟩, виконуємо U, а потім вимірюємо верхню систему Z зі
стандартним базисним вимірюванням. По суті, це перетворює |φ⟩ на |Γ₁⟩, і
просто поглянувши на опис |Γ₁⟩, ми можемо побачити, що це робить те, що стверджує теорема, тобто ми отримуємо
кожен результат a з імовірністю pₐ, і умовно на отримання a система X залишається в стані |ψₐ⟩.
Щоб бути зрозумілим, саме вимірювання, існування якого стверджує теорема, реалізується
всім, що знаходиться в пунктирному прямокутнику на малюнку. І якщо ти хочеш знати, як це
вимірювання можна описати як сукупність матриць, ось їхній вираз. Я не буду пояснювати цю частину — вона
не дуже важлива для прикладу, але це вираз матриць вимірювання, якщо тебе це цікавить.
Далі ми обговоримо вірність — міру того, наскільки схожі два квантових стани, або, альтернативно, наскільки
вони перекриваються. Почнімо з визначення, яке може виглядати трохи загадково на
перший погляд, але ми його розберемо, і наприкінці обговорення я сподіваюся переконати тебе, що це
насправді набагато красивіша функція, ніж може здатися спочатку. Ось
визначення: вірність між двома матрицями густини ρ та σ дорівнює сліду квадратного кореня від добутку квадратного кореня
з ρ, множеного на σ, множеного на квадратний корінь з ρ. Поговоримо про це:
спочатку спробуємо розібратися з самим визначенням. У нас є три квадратних кореня, і
всі вони посилаються на квадратний корінь із додатньо напівдиференційованої матриці, яка, як ми обговорювали на попередньому уроці, є
єдиною додатньо напівдиференційованою матрицею, квадрат якої дає нам матрицю, з якої ми беремо квадратний корінь. Оскільки
ρ — матриця густини, вона обов'язково є додатньо напівдиференційованою, тому ми можемо взяти з неї корінь. А якщо ми подумаємо про корінь із ρ, помножений на
σ, помножений на корінь із ρ, то побачимо, що це також є додатньо напівдиференційованою матрицею, і зокрема ми можемо записати її як
M†·M, де M — квадратний корінь із σ, помножений на квадратний корінь із ρ. Тому ми можемо взяти квадратний
корінь із неї. Зокрема, ми можемо обчислити спектральний розклад від кореня
з ρ, помноженого на σ, помноженого на корінь із ρ, а потім, щоб взяти квадратний корінь, нам просто потрібно взяти квадратні корені з власних
значень і залишити власні вектори без змін. І нарешті, ми беремо слід
цієї матриці, і оскільки слід дорівнює сумі власних значень, ми отримуємо вираз, який маємо прямо
тут. Отже, це, мабуть, те, що ти не хочеш обчислювати вручну загалом. І це пояснення може не давати
особливого розуміння вірності або того, чому нас вона цікавить, але, сподіваюся, воно роз'яснює технічний
сенс формули. До речі, іноді люди визначають вірність як
квадрат функції, яку я визначив тут, і називають цю функцію кореневою
вірністю. Ти побачиш обидва визначення, що, безумовно, може призвести до плутанини, але зазвичай не призводить,
оскільки люди загалом досить ретельно пояснюють, яке визначення вони використовують. І ти також мусиш
бути певним, що робиш те саме. На мій погляд, не існує правильного або неправильного визначення. Я визначаю це
так просто тому, що звик це робити, і дійсно вважаю, що це трохи зручніше, бо я скоріше зведу щось у квадрат,
ніж буду пізніше брати квадратний корінь, коли виникне потреба. Але, звичайно, ти вільний робити свій власний
вибір. Але так чи інакше, повернімося до вірності у тому вигляді, в якому вона визначена тут. Існують інші еквівалентні способи
визначити вірність, і це насправді досить примітна функція в цьому відношенні, яку можна охарактеризувати деякими досить цікавими
способами. Ось досить прямолінійний спосіб переписати визначення у термінах норми сліду, яку ми бачили ближче до
кінця попереднього уроку. Я не вдавався в дуже детальне пояснення норми сліду, зокрема
я навіть не визначав її для не-ермітових матриць, але в неї є достатньо просте визначення. Один спосіб визначити норму сліду
WEBVTT
довільної матриці M полягає в тому, що це слід від квадратного кореня з M·M† або, еквівалентно, слід від квадратного
кореня з M†·M — ти отримаєш однакове значення в будь-якому разі. І ми можемо використати це визначення, щоб спростити
визначення вірності, як показано тут внизу екрана. Це добре, тому що воно розкриває, що
вона є симетричною відносно двох аргументів. Ми також можемо виразити норму сліду квадратної матриці M як
максимум абсолютного значення сліду від M·U за всіма унітарними матрицями U — це не очевидно, але
є правдою. І це дає нам ще один вираз для вірності. Отже, ми маємо три
еквівалентних визначення для вірності, і це лише початок — є кілька інших еквівалентних визначень,
і ми побачимо особливо важливе, яке походить з теореми Уламана ближче до кінця уроку.
Добре, це все чудово, але що все це означає на інтуїтивному рівні і чому нас повинна цікавити ця
функція? Щоб відповісти на ці запитання, корисно розглянути окремий випадок, коли принаймні одна з двох матриць густини
представляє чистий стан. Якщо обидва стани є чистими, то
вірність — це просто абсолютне значення внутрішнього добутку між двома векторами квантових станів, і в певному сенсі
це є головною мотивацією для вірності. Абсолютне значення внутрішнього добутку між двома векторами квантових станів
завжди є числом між нулем і одиницею і дає нам природний спосіб вимірювання того, наскільки два вектори квантових станів перекриваються.
Ти можеш думати про вірність як про корисний і добре поведений спосіб
розширити цей спосіб вимірювання перекриття від чистих станів до матриць густини. Якщо один зі станів є чистим,
а інший не обов'язково є чистим, то знову маємо простий вираз для вірності, який може бути досить
зручним. І цей вираз показано прямо тут. Вірність має багато цікавих
властивостей, і саме тому люди її використовують. Вона має визначення, яке насправді не є
особливо гарним, але є дуже корисною функцією тим не менш, і з нею часто дуже легко працювати частково завдяки її багатьом
дивовижним властивостям. Тому давай подивимося на деякі з них, починаючи зі спостереження, що вірність між двома матрицями
густини завжди є числом між 0 і 1. Вона дорівнює нулю тоді й тільки тоді, коли стани
є ортогональними, тобто образи є ортогональними підпросторами, або еквівалентно, добуток двох матриць дорівнює
нулю. І вірність дорівнює одиниці тоді й тільки тоді, коли дві матриці густини рівні. Кожен інший випадок знаходиться десь
посередині, але інтуїтивно кажучи, чим ближче вірність до одиниці, тим більш схожими є стани, або, альтернативно,
тим більше вони перекриваються. Вірність також є симетричною — я згадував про це кілька хвилин тому. Це
досить ясно видно з виразу вірності через норму сліду, але це важливо визнати
тим не менш. Далі вірність є мультиплікативною для добуткових станів, тобто вірність між двома
добутковими станами завжди дорівнює добутку вірностей між окремими
станами. Ось дуже корисна властивість: якщо у нас є будь-які дві матриці густини однакового розміру
разом із будь-яким каналом, що приймає ці матриці густини на вхід, то вірність може лише збільшуватися, коли цей канал
застосовується до обох станів. Іншими словами, з погляду вірності канали можуть лише робити стани
більш схожими один на одного — вони не можуть зробити їх менш схожими. І нарешті, для цього списку принаймні,
існує досить тісний зв'язок між вірністю та трасовою відстанню між станами, яка визначається
як половина норми сліду різниці двох матриць густини. Трасова відстань між двома
станами тісно пов'язана з тим, наскільки добре ми можемо їх розрізнити, що ми обговорювали на попередньому уроці в контексті
розрізнення станів та теореми Хелстрома–Голева. Тоді як вірність кількісно визначає, наскільки два стани
перекриваються. Тому, хоча це не є абсолютно одним і тим самим, не дивно, що між цими
двома величинами існує зв'язок. У будь-якому разі ці нерівності, які зазвичай називають нерівностями Фукса–ван де Граафа, роблять
цей зв'язок математично точним. Важливо, що тут абсолютно немає залежності від розміру системи, про яку ми
говоримо. Ми можемо бачити цей зв'язок дещо чіткіше за допомогою малюнка: якщо у нас є два стани і ми
відкладаємо трасову відстань між ними по осі X, а вірність — по осі Y, то відповідні вертикальні
та горизонтальні лінії мають перетинатися десь у межах цієї сірої ділянки. Найцікавіша ділянка
графіка, принаймні з практичної точки зору, — верхній лівий кут сірої ділянки. Зокрема, коли
трасова відстань дуже мала, вірність обов'язково дуже близька до одиниці, і навпаки.
Ці нерівності використовуються дуже часто, і частково тому, що ми часто більше нас цікавить
трасова відстань в кінцевому підсумку, оскільки вона має природну інтерпретацію, пов'язану з розрізненням квантових станів.
Але вірність має стільки дивовижних властивостей, що з нею загалом легше працювати, і поки ми знаходимося у верхньому лівому куті
сірої ділянки, де ми часто й знаходимося, ми не втрачаємо надто багато, конвертуючи між вірністю та трасовою відстанню. Отже,
це деякі властивості вірності — є ще багато, але це гарний початок, і сподіваюся, список допомагає
починати розвивати деяку інтуїцію щодо вірності. Ось гарний приклад того, як ми
можемо пов'язати вірність із неруйнівними вимірюваннями. Це дуже зручний факт, відомий як лема про
м'яке вимірювання. Припустимо, що у нас є система X, стан X, представлений матрицею густини ρ, і вимірювання системи X,
описане сукупністю додатньо напівдиференційованих матриць. Припустимо, що один із результатів вимірювання дуже ймовірно
з'явиться, якщо ми виконаємо вимірювання стану ρ. Для простоти припустимо,
що це результат «нуль», який дуже ймовірний. І зокрема припустимо, що цей результат з'являється з
імовірністю, більшою за 1 − ε, для деякого малого значення ε, яке нам насправді не потрібно вказувати. ε —
просто деяке мале додатнє дійсне число. Тепер ми описали наше вимірювання так, ніби воно є руйнівним
вимірюванням, але ми знаємо з попереднього уроку, що ми могли б реалізувати це вимірювання неруйнівним способом. Зокрема, ми могли б це зробити так,
як ми бачили в нашому обговоренні теореми Ноймарка: кожен результат a з'являється з
імовірністю, що дорівнює сліду від Pₐ·ρ, і умовно на отримання цього результату стан X змінюється.
WEBVTT
Зокрема, у випадку, коли ми отримуємо ймовірний результат нуль, стан стає квадратним коренем із P₀, помноженим на ρ, помноженим на квадратний корінь із P₀,
нормованим, щоб отримати матрицю густини. І що говорить нам лема про м'яке вимірювання, так це те, що в цьому випадку,
тобто коли ми справді отримуємо ймовірний результат вимірювання, стан, який ми отримуємо, не змінився б
дуже сильно від початкового. Зокрема, квадрат вірності обов'язково буде більшим за 1 мінус
ε. І це чудово, тому що це є цілком загальним: ми взагалі нічого не сказали про вимірювання або
стан, крім того, що один із результатів дуже ймовірний. Тому лему можна застосовувати в
багатьох різних ситуаціях, де ми хочемо щось перевірити про квантовий стан, не дуже порушуючи його. Отже, давай подивимося, як це можна довести.
Загалом це досить просте обчислення вірності між станами до та після вимірювання.
Ми можемо зробити це, використовуючи початкове визначення, і зазвичай це могло б залишити нас з заплутаною формулою, але
у цьому випадку нам щастить, тому що те, що знаходиться всередині зовнішнього квадратного кореня, насправді є квадратом матриці, яка
є додатньо напівдиференційованою, що робить обчислення квадратного кореня тривіальним. Тепер ми можемо використовувати циклічну
властивість сліду разом із лінійністю сліду, щоб спростити наш вираз, як показано на екрані. Зауваж до речі, що це
всі рівності, тому ми ще нічого не наближували. Ми справді просто спрощуємо. Але тепер нам потрібна
нерівність, тому що ми хочемо позбутися цього квадратного кореня в чисельнику. І справді можемо це зробити, якщо погодимося задовольнитися нижньою межею. І якщо
тобі цікаві деталі цієї частини, ти можеш досить легко отримати нерівність, розглянувши спектральний розклад P₀.
Власні значення P₀ мають бути між 0 і 1 — це завжди правда для матриць, що описують
вимірювання. І як тільки ми знаємо це, нерівність досить безпосередньо випливає з того факту, що взяття квадратного кореня
з числа між 0 і 1 може лише збільшити його. Інший спосіб сказати це: зведення числа між 0 і
1 у квадрат може лише зменшити його. Тепер ми можемо спростити ще трохи і отримуємо квадратний
корінь зі сліду від P₀·ρ. Нарешті, зводячи обидві частини у квадрат і
підставляючи нашу межу на ймовірність, ми отримуємо те, що хочемо. Отже, формула для вірності
не є найкрасивішою або найзручнішою формулою у світі, але тут вона справді спрацьовує досить
добре. На завершення уроку ми розглянемо теорему Уламана — фундаментальний факт про вірність, який
пов'язує її з поняттям очищення. Що стверджує теорема простими словами: вірність між будь-якими двома
квантовими станами дорівнює максимальному внутрішньому добутку (за абсолютним значенням) між двома очищеннями цих
станів. Трохи детальніше: припустимо, що ρ і σ — матриці густини для деякої системи X, і нехай Y — це
система, яка має принаймні стільки ж класичних станів, скільки й X. Тоді ми гарантовано маємо, що обидва ці стани мають очищення, які є
векторами квантових станів XY. Ми можемо тоді виразити наслідок теореми у вигляді рівняння,
показаного на екрані: вірність між ρ та σ дорівнює максимальному абсолютному значенню внутрішнього добутку
між |φ⟩ і |ψ⟩, взятого за всіма |φ⟩ та |ψ⟩, що очищують ρ і σ
відповідно. Отже, давай приведемо це до ладу і надалі будемо працювати з точним математичним твердженням. Тепер ми доведемо
теорему, але спочатку варто зупинитися і оцінити, що вона пропонує досить інтуїтивний спосіб думати про
вірність. Вона також є досить корисною сама по собі, наприклад, щоб довести ще цікавіші факти про
вірність. Щоб довести її, ми починаємо зі спектральних розкладів наших матриць
густини — без сюрпризів. Маючи спектральні розклади, легко придумати
два конкретних очищення цих станів. Але тут ми насправді використаємо
трюк: зауваж, що в обох випадках у нас немає стандартного базисного вектора як другого тензорного множника, як це було раніше на
уроці, а є той самий вектор, що й у першому тензорному множнику, але з рисочкою над ним. Це означає
покоефіцієнтне комплексне спряження цих векторів. Іншими словами, ми по суті беремо другу копію власних
векторів, але беремо комплексне спряження кожного елемента. І ми побачимо, чому ми так робимо за кілька
хвилин, але це зовсім не очевидно, що потрібно саме це робити. Тому ми й називаємо це
трюком. У будь-якому разі це є очищеннями ρ і σ відповідно. І це правда завдяки
тому факту, що наші власні вектори є ортонормованими, а тому і їхні покоефіцієнтні комплексні спряження є ортонормованими. Тепер ми можемо застосувати
унітарну еквівалентність очищень, яка говорить, що кожне очищення наших двох станів можна отримати,
застосувавши унітарну операцію до системи, яку виводять. Для конкретних вибраних нами очищень
унітарні операції не обов'язково мають бути однаковими для двох очищень,
звичайно. Тому тут ми використовуємо літеру U для першого та літеру V для другого.
Отже, суть у тому, що кожне очищення наших двох станів можна записати так, як ми маємо на екрані, для
деякого вибору унітарних операцій U і V. І тепер ми можемо взяти вираз
з теореми і спростити: якщо ми підставимо наші вирази для |φ⟩ та |ψ⟩ і спростимо трохи, ми
отримаємо вираз, показаний тут на екрані. Там є кілька кроків, і я не показував деталей,
але дозволь зауважити, що причина, чому ми вибрали очищення саме так, полягала в тому, щоб дозволити цьому внутрішньому добутку спростити саме таким чином.
Зокрема, ми поставили комплексні спряження, щоб ефективно мати можливість перевернути внутрішні добутки в другому тензорному множнику, щоб отримати конкретну
форму, яку ми маємо тут. Ми вже майже готові. Тепер ми можемо використовувати циклічну властивість сліду разом
зі спектральними розкладами, з яких ми починали, щоб отримати цей вираз. І на цьому етапі ми можемо
використати один із альтернативних способів виразити вірність через норму сліду, і ми
готові. Звичайно, є деталі, над якими я пробіг дуже швидко, і це той тип доказу, який тобі
справді потрібно пройти самостійно, щоб повністю зрозуміти. Але сподіваюся, це дає тобі основну
ідею. Як завжди, ти можеш знайти більше деталей у письмових матеріалах до уроку, посилання на які є в описі відео.
Це кінець уроку, який був присвячений очищенням, вірності та зв'язкам між ними. Це також
кінець блоку, присвяченого загальному формулюванню квантової інформації. Сподіваюся, ти приєднаєшся до мене для
WEBVTT
четвертого і останнього блоку серії, присвяченого квантовому виправленню помилок. Дякую за перегляд.